perfect here we go Fisher random can you
hear it already can you hear that sound
can you see that text in the chat the
one that runs why are the pieces like
that why are they like that shouldn't
the night be here okay this guy is
unprotected this guy is unprotected
neither one are going to be accessible
on the on the first move like I can't
target this one or this one and there's
no tricky Night Moves I don't think to
get to these squares so quickly what a
tough arrangement here these nights are
brutal okay um in order to Castle
kingside I need to move my queen and
that's it ah let's see I don't know what
I should be doing what about how how
about that why did I go with that I know
I should I shouldn't have gone with that
what do I think this is a bird's opening
this one for the birds um well i guess
like the last thought I had before I
actually move that piece was if he ever
gets captured my rook is gonna come to
life on the F file cuz i am i'm thinking
about i am thinking about
castling King side ah ok well when I do
this
I guess I could play night f to Bishop
check I could always meet with something
like g3 not really a problem these are
these are easy moves to fall victim to
or just enjoy the parish I should say
just to forget about bump this up so
that I want to kind of keep this
structure right here so he's neutralized
black is going with something that's
very solid getting the bishop outside of
a light square pawn chain I could do
this and then not here maybe just say
you know what I don't want to Castle
kingside anymore maybe I do want to do
that though know what I am going to do
that if Bishop check a block with my
night because I pretty much have to and
the reason I'm seeing why this might
turn out to be very good is because the
bishop has to back up to g6 and when it
does kind of clogs up that night
position so let's see if I can make that
work ooh you know what I am able to make
work this Bishop getting trapped not see
I didn't see that until just now but
actually this Bishop has been going to
be a dead duck a dead duck so now really
all I'm the only number crunching I'm
doing right now is with regard to how to
outages capture pawn takes or rip takes
i think i'll play f5 to follow and I
think the bishop is just out of squares
I am aware of this queen bee for move
giving check and it has some lateral
movement but I already have a
counter-attacking move so there's not
too much to calculate in that or there's
not really its Queen before is not
really an issue hmm
does it really matter I don't think it
really matters I'll just take with the
rook I don't know why I was waiting so
long with that I had to take actually I
shouldn't have even been thinking about
what the what ifs with Queen before I I
don't know either way this is not going
to be influenced like the Queen ok she
rakes this fourth rank but my bishop is
there to watch over h5 if there is first
to capture in fact maybe it's best that
black doesn't capture and just lets the
bishops it here certainly a tough
position but the reason I'm saying it
maybe should have SAT there is because
now this rook is you know he's this is
exactly what he wants a half open G file
so ok black and castle quickly i do
still have to complete development
couldn't castle like right now this
night does not have to move in order to
Castle Queen side I have to clear up
these I can't Castle kingside of course
I had to move this truck I need to move
both bishops before I can go Queen side
and if you're new to this that would be
done by picking up my king and dropping
it on my rook and then my king would end
up on see one in my rook would end up on
d1 ok but what is black do in the
meantime I don't really see it there's
castles there's a check but again I just
be doing these kantai counter-attacking
move um let's go with it and I'm just
ruling that out right away there's no
need to even take the bishop he's not
going anywhere I think I just helped out
the black development by taking right
now and you know what I could do
whoo if I play Bishop g4 there's an h 5
move takes with check let's not even get
into that I'm going to take now and then
give a check and then queenside castle
okay so I have the piece I'm just
looking for activity get my night out of
the corner there's not any other square
that he could go to my rook okay let's
slide step this attack actually my rook
is no longer needed on G so let's get
them to the F file instead of making a
instead of sidestepping the threat with
my queen just get one of my pieces who
really wasn't doing something doing
something and okay night needs to come
out I guess we could be having this
let's get my queen to g2 and my other
book to f1 and I guess my bishop could
be kicked around a little bit with h5
and maybe there's then this move okay
take your first and then I hit the Queen
I want to make sure I keep control over
this F file where do I want to go with
my bishop this Bishop can do one better
by being on this main diagonal corner to
corner dark square diagonal do I really
care about giving up my light square
Bishop I really don't well wait maybe I
do Bishop here Knight takes Queen takes
pawn I don't want to give up this one
then these guys become past all of them
so what would be better do I play here
and box out the night or do I just back
up and stand this diagonal
um I like this I like that little kind
of that little V line that the bishop
makes to negate the night from advancing
peace improvement is where it's at right
now I do okay if Bishop c3 there's maybe
night a for that could be a bit annoying
I'd like to exchange off this night for
either one of those guys he's stupid on
b3 I'm basically just looking for trades
here this night is within checking
distance I could still do Queen g3 to
place this night in the pin but I
couldn't do that if the pond wasn't here
protecting the Queen what is black do
challenge me on the F file created a
flight square for the king with 86 a
repositioning of the night ok I could
jump in here welcome a night exchange
but what I like better than the night
exchange is of course a queen exchange
if you watched even a few of my games
you will know that that is the case love
a queen exchange all right now how about
we just trade night here with tempo
mmm right here I could do
let's go here bishop it's that Queen I
didn't see really the follow up if I did
night c5 queen e 7 so that's why I went
with jeep this bishop here I guess just
trade queens get into a position where
I'm ready to trade cleans Queen f4 Queen
Queen f7 I guess the night to come back
here
30 second warning 30 seconds remaining
here I guess queen here Queen here is
very active let's trade a little bit can
we please trade okay let's stay right
here I'd like to play b3 and King be to
just small improvements but I guess
Queen check is a little bit annoying i
know i think i could still do it oh it's
just that's just a blunder was actually
that meant or was this just not seen
could have been the case time issue as
well no good solution this night is
going to be lost however you slice it
however you slice it and there is no
stalemate alright resign time okay honey
let's back up good game flip I don't
know how great a start I had really with
f4i to be honest I like I like this idea
with your bishop but you know what this
unfortunately turns out to kind of
backfire does it not because of my g
four and five idea that's tough to deal
with he ended up getting crunched and I
didn't see it I played g4 and I didn't
even realize at that moment that I was
going to be winning the bishop but I do
end up winning that Bishop so maybe
maybe after all this idea of jumping in
with the Bishop f5 is not a good idea
because of this expansion huh who would
have thought yeah i mean this this is
fine i think if this bishop isn't around
here because whenever i threatened
something like g4 maybe you could be
doing h5 or something but now this is
this is a problem this this position
turns out to backfire so what maybe
might be what might be something better
huh two off here this is pretty tough
maybe get your another pond side by side
right here it's way too difficult for me
to even suggest something there's so
there's so many different things that
you could be doing from this initial
position but I guess you really just
beware of the possibilities I have to
expand and be grabbing more space with
my pawns that's kind of what it turned
out too that's that's what ended up
happening right purposeful get my dark
square Bishop out I take away another
square that turns out to be a problem
usually it wouldn't this g4 move usually
there isn't a knight or a bishop here g4
wouldn't be supported in a regular chess
game but Wow seems like you just have to
always be calculating right for move one
with these 9 60 s very easy to get into
a bad position quickly the check was
okay I mean the check was no bother to
white this this is still going to be an
issue I don't think that I gave you
anything to I don't know we just traded
down maybe that was a slip at the end
but yeah just I guess be very cautious
of the ideas very early on in the
possibilities for pond advances grabbing
a lot of space not sure really what else
to add okay